i'm a big fan of the road trip you're a
big fan of the road trip the long hikes
out in rural nevada there is so much to
see and do around the silver state there
really is we live in a great place so
bianca holman joining us live now with
john burke host of outdoor nevada
what a fun thing to be able to talk
about all the national parks and the
sports that we can do
and even skateboarding
good morning
yes
heather and john again we are adding
these spots to our list and john i know
you like to go out and explore
well you want to go out and explore with
this guy john berg here so tell us more
about some of the amazing spots that you
have ventured out to during during this
year and this season there there are so
many and you know sometimes just getting
to the location is as good as being at
the location itself if you drive along
the loneliest highway in america highway
50 there's a little place called
middleton and there's a little hamlet
and they got a little bar and they got a
little restaurant they got hamburgers
that are so big that if you can eat it
you get it free wow yeah and there's
little rooms that you can rent to stay
in and this is out in the middle of
nowhere nobody knows about it but if
you'll just get outside of las vegas go
two hours north i'm telling you there's
things that will change your life gold
butte national monument this is
incredible because again outside of the
lights outside the vegas lights give us
if we have a family let's say i got some
a kid who's eight you know it's me in
the hubby and another one who's three
years old right i got a family where
would you recommend we go to on a
saturday okay so the first thing i'm
doing is going to cathedral gorge it's
about two and a half hours north and
it's like being on the set of star wars
and there's all these slot canyons it's
like bryce canyon without the people so
go there take the kids it will get you
out of your comfort zone and you can
still be back in time for dinner good
good so many day trips that we can do
and a lot of people are looking for that
because again money might be a little
tight but it's towards the end of summer
so you want some place to go to
and again hey if you're an adventurer
okay john langley he likes to venture
out and i know you've met some amazing
people like our long boarder here shane
so also what if you're like to do
outdoor activities where would you say
you should go well here's the thing you
just mentioned shane perfect example of
somebody that's on outdoor nevada this
particular season season five which
premieres next wednesday at 7 30 on
vegas pbs
slash outdoor nevada
we've got all kinds of great people like
this guy who travels around in a van and
sells his longboards to to fund the
trips i met a guy who takes care of
what's called desert dumping people that
are dumping their trash in the desert
one guy in the mojave is out there
cleaning it up this place is full of
heroes yeah so many stories so many
places to see again i hope you got your
pen out and you're writing some things
down
but amazing things that we get to
explore right here in the silver state
i'm going to send it back to you guys in
the studio you know bianca they showed
video you were showing video of rhyolite
the ghost town up near death valley
before you know the good thing about
ghost towns most of them are there's no
money there you don't have to spend any
money because there's go there's nothing
there it's a ghost town it's literally a
ghost town so it's
free we're talking about ghost towns
ghost towns yeah rhyolites are beautiful
this state is full of ghost stories and
ghost towns
i spent the night in a hotel room with a
ghost yeah yeah that's that's the cleary
towel well there's the claw motel in the
mid spa as well that's where there's a
lady of the night will visit you we'll
talk it's good stuff there's so much to
do thanks a lot bianca thank you john as
well appreciate it